[Music]
kelly is with us kelly is in warner
robins georgia hi kelly what's up
hi dave hi chrissy how you guys doing
great what's going on can we help
so
i have quite a few financial questions
but i'm going to stick with the one that
i'm with with right now um
i'm one it's a 401k question and i have
seen
and watched a couple of free videos with
people who have about the same questions
with using your 401k to pay off debt and
i know that it is not a good idea i'm
completely aware of it
um
i don't have a lot in my
401k
so in in my opinion i don't feel like
i'm taking that heart of it and i know
it will because i think it takes like 30
now i'm in the lower tax bracket
um
basically what i'm wanting to use it for
is to
purchase a vehicle that i don't know any
money on
um i currently have a
truck loan that i'm wanting to get rid
of i want to come up from
this truck loan
so
my plan is to sell
it and then
use what what out of my
401k kind of what's left over after i
purchase a vehicle
to
kind of pay off like the other little
bit of debt that i do have i have a
total of
25
500 in debt and the majority of that is
from my truck how much of this is the
truck
it's 19 300. and how much is in your
401k
i only have 13 000. um that's between i
have so kelly essentially what you're
saying is this okay
in order to execute my plan
i want to borrow 13 000
at 30 percent interest
okay
that's what you're saying
now you're not saying it directly but
that is the effect
of your proposal
okay when the smoke clears and that's
why you've heard this call so many times
as you've watched youtube on the same
subject
and um
here's what's happening and i commend
you for trying to figure out a way out
of this because you've recognized the
truck is the problem and it's got to go
and i really think you're very wise in
that regard
but but what ends up happening is um
i know you because i am you i see you in
the mirror when i look in it and we're
people that we rip the band-aid off
people even if it hurts i want to be
done with it
yes
and
and we have a tendency in making our
financial decisions to let that color
our decision
um
and we don't really i i have
i just i did this stuff in my 20s and i
know exactly how
i know the feeling that you're like i
just want to get this over with
that is that correct
yes yes because i see
i see it as hurting me more than i am
like because all of my money is going to
these loans and
i'm actually able to pay it i would
rather have it going
towards like saving i would rather put
that
it's a 400 so
since you bought the truck you've had a
wake-up call and and you've yeah you
know that's in the rear view mirror no
pun intended and um you know you're
looking back there and you're going ted
gummit and i got to clean this up now
and
but we've but truthfully i want you to
find a
more painful
slower or a slower way to clean this up
that is more painful on the short term
and less painful on the long term here's
a principle for everybody out there
when it comes to money if it feels good
this week
but bad
over the period of a decade
then it's the wrong decision
right and that's what this one is it
falls in that bucket
because it feels good to cash this out
and clean up all these bills and do all
this other stuff so what do you make a
year
um
it's i'm actually basing it off of my
husband's income because i just recently
within six months have started a
cleaning business
so i make um from the numbers that i
pulled up within last month i've made
about eight hundred dollars a month so i
don't make much maybe seven hundred or
seven seven thousand a year what does he
make
about 24 000 a year he brings in about a
480 paycheck every week gotcha now this
truck is killing you then how much is
the truck worth
um i kelly blue booked it at
20
oh no
oh what did the lady tell me i just
remember her telling me don't ever go
less than fifteen thousand um
well i i recently did a quote with
carmax and they told me that they would
give me 17 for it so i mean i would only
owe two grand on it and i know
if you if you sell it if you sell it
private sale it'll bring enough to pay
it off yes that's that's where i'm going
with this kelly because there is a
quicker path to where you want to get
and it doesn't involve
sacrificing you don't have a car then
but if you but even if you got something
in cash small like a thousand two
thousand dollar card do you have any
savings kelly
i've got a little bit um not much what's
a little bit um which is crazy how much
is a little bit
two thousand i have two thousand dollars
okay i want you to sell the truck for 19
and buy two thousand dollar car
okay and then i want you to work your
butt off without the truck payment and
being on a budget get your cleaning
business going the great news is that
you can actually make a lot of money in
the cleaning business and you need more
accounts
or you need to raise your prices or
something because oh my goodness i'm
surprised that it did it's doing what
it's doing within the six months like i
don't know oh no no you should have been
doing that in month one we're gonna
change that mindset kelly if you'll stay
on the line we'll have kelly here give
you a ticket to our business boutique
conference in october it's october 14th
through the 16th we'll show you how to
raise your prices we'll show you how to
market your business we'll show you how
to get customers and get more money
that's going to help you
pay off that debt we do it every year
every fall thousands how much you can do
this yeah not counting the truck only
about five thousand dollars right
six thousand yeah i've got i've got a
personal loan at 1200 and then my credit
card is five thousand okay yeah sell the
truck
sell the truck for enough to pay it off
buy a two thousand dollar car and cut up
your credit card get yourself on a tight
budget hang on kelly will pick up and
we're going to get you signed up for
business boutique in the meantime we're
also going to send you the business
boutique book and between now and
october i want you to double your income
and then when you come to business
boutique you can double it again
because you should be making four five
six thousand bucks a month in a cleaning
business right now it's a it's a
freaking gold mine
it's the ultimate we just answered a
question about this with the
blinds.com from an 18 year old of of
having a cleaning business
painting oh i'm sorry
painting sorry but i'm telling you this
let me let me give you guys so
this is this
so when daniel my son who's a senior
vice president here now and he's an old
man with a baby in the whole bit now but
when he was a kid
we were remodeling doing some remodeling
at our house
and i was ready to kill him
because they wouldn't show up yeah
so we're driving down the street he's 14
years old and he goes
uh dad i think i've decided what my
career is i said what he goes i'm gonna
be a contractor
and i'm like why
and he said it looks to me like there's
no competition because all you have to
do is show up when you said you were
going to
meet the price you said you were going
to
and do good work and he goes none of
those are rocket science this is a 14
year old the bar is low i'm just saying
you got no competition in the maid
service business and in the none yeah
and in the remodeling business or
handyman business i talked to a handyman
the other day making 300k a year
you know what is so interesting though
in the way that kelly talked about that
even though it's just i'm surprised
that i'm making 800 i'm surprised
that's what i want to fix the mindset oh
my god people are giving me charity they
paid me eight no no no you're running
you clean their
the marketplace when you start changing
your mind about your business what it
does the money you can make what you're
worth you will start seeing that money
but as long as you
feel pitiful and act pitiful the results
you will get will be pitiful i a lot of
and you've seen this dave a lot of what
i do through business boutique whether
it's at the conference or book or
whatever is changing the mindset because
that's what changes the actual cringe
injecting courage
my specialty
with it's a big old courage
and just makes you believe because it's
funny once you think you're worth
something you you sound stuck up but
you're not stuck up you go it's
confidence you go do it you go work
there's a lot of difference in
confidence and arrogance yes